[Applause]
[Music]
football is the biggest show in the
world no event paralyzes a planet like
the World Cup final the United States
has the Super Bowl India and Pakistan go
crazy for a cricket match but in the end
it's football that unites a Nigerian
with an Argentinian and a Brazilian with
a journey
[Music]
so why are we talking about football on
visual politic because as you can
imagine football is also political and
influences the economy after all
television stations spend a fortune on
the broadcast rights for football
matches to give you an idea for just one
season the English league the so-called
Premier League receives almost 3.5
billion euros in television rights
so as you'll appreciate football is more
than twenty two blokes kicking a ball
around spitters been a sport for the
masses for many decades now but since
the 1990s it's become big business there
are many interests at stake and
governments are frequently among them
for example in Spain where in 1997 the
government passed a law that required
teams to broadcast the best match of
each week on free-to-air television
simply because this was reflected by law
soccer has been considered a national
interest since the 1960s but all this
changed in recent years watching a big
match for free has become incredibly
rare as you probably know pay TV has
made off with all the rights of a
football I mean if you want to watch
games you have to pay and that was the
status quo until we heard about this
[Music]
league working on plans for
revolutionary Netflix style streaming
channel which will net them billions in
cash a football
Netflix something like this could well
mark the end of paid TV channels I mean
why am I gonna pay a fortune to have
hundreds of channels that are not
interested in the slightest there's a
ton of stuff available on YouTube or
Netflix or HBO
what does pay TV really offer well what
will happen in the future is unclear but
there's no doubt that these pay TV
platforms Sky movie star all those that
could lose football will fight fiercely
to keep football on offer and this fight
is gonna kick off a political struggle
so the question is could pay TV
platforms disappear how can they find
emerging services likely proposed prend
leaks what political implications could
this whole thing have well today we're
going to answer these questions but
first let's take a look back at the
history
bread and circus being emperor in Rome
had an upside ends an inconvenience the
advantage was that it was a lifetime
position there were no bothersome
elections or anything like that the
downside was that the opposition only
had two methods of changing Emperor's
poison or dagger so the Emperor's were
constantly looking over their shoulders
trying to increase their popularity and
countered they do it well as seen the
movie Gladiator and I was by handing out
bread to the crowd and organizing games
in the circus every so often the famous
bred circus spread to fill the stomachs
and the circus to keep people
entertained and although many centuries
have passed we humans haven't changed
all that much modern football emerged in
England in the mid nineteenth century
within a few decades had become a mass
sport more than a hundred thousand
people attended the English Cup final in
1901 in 1908 the first official
international tournament was held as
part of the London Olympics from that
moment on football's growth was almost
unstoppable
if football was already successful as a
clash between clubs representing
different cities you can only imagine
what it would be like when countries
faced off it was an era when most of
Europe had just lived through the Great
War and was heading to an even greater
one in 1930 Uruguay held the first World
if this inaugural World Cup was a
sporting success completely separate
from politics a second one was the
opposite Mussolini's Italy hosted the
world carpenter duche was obsessed with
using football as a means of propaganda
referees were bribed black shirts were
peppered in the stands and the final was
played at the fascist National Stadium
just in case rivals had any doubts about
where they were playing of course Italy
won that
and the next World Cup players from the
Italian national team received a
telegram from Mussolini saying win or
die and you can guess who want that
World Cup it was Italy they've had that
priority clear in this country for a
long time football is the most important
thing of the least important things our
ego Saatchi italian coach and yes I know
you're thinking Mussolini it was extreme
he was a fascist dictator but what
happens in a democracy well you remember
Silvio Berlusconi his success as
president of AC Milan in the 1990s paved
the way for him to become the president
of Italy or even more recently Mauricio
Macri who went from being presidents of
the Boca Juniors to mayor of whereas
Aires and then President of Argentina
[Music]
it was also in Argentina that the 1978
World Cup took place two years earlier
there had been a coup when the World Cup
was held there who was played during one
the most terrible military dictatorships
of the 20th century general Vidya took
advantage of the World Cup to clean up
the regime's image on the international
stage as you can imagine only Argentina
could win the Cup and if that meant it
needed to win 6-0 to Peru to reach the
final that miraculously achieved that
score this was later regretted by
Ricardo via one of the players on the
winning side in that World Cup he used
us to cover up 30,000 disappearances I
feel cheated and I assume my individual
responsibility I was a fool I didn't see
beyond the ball the Cardo via
Argentinian soccer player something
similar could have been planned for the
World Cup in Spain in 1982 hosting the
events was won by the Franco
dictatorship but when it came time to
celebrate the World Cup that
dictatorship had already been replaced
by a democracy in Spain so even if
people are scratching their heads
because Qatar is going to host a
football World Cup as you can see this
has been happening for decades FIFA and
dictatorships do get along rather well
and football has become a spectacle that
many try to take advantage are there
political purposes as soon as they have
an opportunity but this is all politics
now let's look at the business side of
things check this out
[Music]
the greatest spectacle in the world the
European leagues are organized like
private companies as you can see in this
Deloitte chart the Premier League
generates a lot more revenue than the
other European leagues it gets more for
all the areas reflected in the graph but
the big difference is in the television
rights
that's where English clubs really clean
up and of course so much money has
consequences this was illustrated by
what happened in 2019 the English League
was won by Manchester City the Champions
League final was between Liverpool and
Tottenham the Europa League final was
between Chelsea and Arsenal in other
words English clubs are threatening to
dominate Europe and if you think this is
purely by chance
it's because you have a minute following
news like this West Bromwich I'll be on
bottom of the Premier League earns more
money than electical Madrid for
television rights on Tina 3 so it's
clear that having money is no guarantee
of success just look at Manchester
United's but the truth is that the
Premier League has been doing its
homework diligently for 30 years what's
more the appearance of the Premier
League marks the moment when football
became a gigantic money-making machine
it all started in 1992 when the 22 clubs
in the first division left the English
Football Federation to create a Premier
League why well because the clubs wanted
to negotiate the TV rights on their own
and basically Skye Rupert Murdoch's pay
TV channel was willing to pay 10 times
more than the BBC had been paying it
really negotiated a great deal
[Music]
from the outset the English clubs
decided that half the money paid from
television would be split equally among
all Premier League members another 25%
would depend on their league position
and another 25% on the number of
televised matches all this has made the
chef's English teams much higher than in
leagues like the Spanish one in fact
such has been the success of this model
the Spanish league copied it five years
ago but not everyone involved thought it
was a great idea the government
regulated centralized sales against Real
Madrid's which wanted to continue doing
business on its own in any case this
decree culminated in the Football Wars
in Spain remember what I told you about
how the law required teams to show one
free-to-air league game on television
for ten years the Spanish clubs tried to
end that tradition eventually the
government relented the league which did
not want free football on television
went on to decide which matches could be
seen for free by everyone hence well
what happens well it's been a very long
time since there's a free-to-air game
involving Real Madrid Barcelona
aesthetic owned Madrid or Valencia and
that's how we end up with news like this
he decides not to award free-to-air
match for low price offered Ilocano mr.
so what does this mean well it's not
profitable to televise football just
because it's football games from lower
in the league just don't generate that
much interest on TV but if these matches
are put in a package and it's up for
auction well in the past you'd pay about
350 million euros for just the 38
matches between Real Madrid and
Barcelona how about you pay me three
times as much but in return you can
televise all 380 League games absolutely
every match that explains the success of
the Premier League model it saw where
the business was 30 years ago
and knew how to maximize it and now the
English clubs are thinking of launching
their prem flicks and what might happen
or maybe this get rid of the middleman
there's no question that football on pay
TV is a successful formula this is
demonstrated by UEFA itself which in its
last Champions League auction announced
that if bidders intended to give free
matches they wouldn't be considered as
the entire Champions League would be
passed exclusively to pay TV until then
UEFA preferred launch television
audiences in order to ask the tournament
sponsors for more money but it has
reached a point where football fans are
subscribed to pay TV so UEFA has opted
for the direct profitability offered by
these platforms the numbers don't lie
sky leads pay TV in the UK with 9
million subscribers and in Spain movie
star which has the rights to all
football has more than 4 million
subscribers and Counting
[Music]
a TV shoots up and doubles its figures
from 12 years ago ABC the key to this
growth is football but not just for
football as the star product actually
many of these platforms don't make money
from football itself but thanks to
football they get huge volumes of
subscribers and these subscribers enjoy
the Italian league the French league
basketball formula one cinema series and
on top of that there's also the internet
connection it all rounds out in one
convenient bill which sounds pretty good
and this business model sounded great
until the Premier League caught and on
and worked on its own numbers if a
football fan is willing to pay more or
less about a thousand euros a year for
all this what happens if you skip the
middleman well it might look something
like this
the overall Premier League audience
reaches a billion households if at least
a hundred million of those households
become your customers and you charge
them the equivalent of a Netflix fee
about eight to nine euros per month
that's a hundred euros a year so how
much money could Prem flicks raise
somewhere around 10 billion euros which
is more than double of the Premier
League gross right now
[Music]
the launch of a Netflix star football
service would be a terrible blow to pay
TV platforms although they may offer a
lot more than football if they lose
football content they'll have a huge
loss in customers after all football is
clearly the content that people are
willing to pay for in the vast majority
of cases this may or may not happen it's
pure speculation but I'm sure that if
parental expose ahead television
platforms will turn to politicians to
try and stop it
what can they do if television
consumption moves to OTT over-the-top
environments that is to the on-demand
content that is readily available on the
Internet see that free of charge like
YouTube or pay-per-view such as Netflix
what is clear is that fewer and fewer
people will be interested in traditional
channels and this is when the pure
speculation comes in but it seems that
if all this happens we can expect a
brutal war in which television channels
will put pressure on governments they do
have a public influence they're willing
to use it in exchange for politicians
creating laws to ban football broadcasts
outside the traditional television
channels yes probably think it makes no
sense for politics to be involved in
this matter it's purely a financial
issue between private entities isn't it
but don't forget the football regulation
and logic don't always go hand in hand
or does it make sense for football clubs
that rake in millions for their TV
rights to be allowed exclusive use of
stadiums owned by City Council's course
not meanwhile British pay TV platforms
are not wasting any time and they are
extending their operations to other mass
sports such as rugby
Six Nations could be off free-to-air TV
as Sky Sports is favorite to snatch
rights from the BBC in 300 million pound
Deal Daily Mail what will be keeping an
eye on what goes on with this football
war but now the question is over to you
would you like a Netflix star service of
Hubble how much would you be willing to
pay to watch your team's games well
leave your answer in the comments below
and I really do hope you enjoyed this
video please do hit like if you did
don't forget to subscribe
also do check out our friends at the
ricans of the media podcast and thank
you for watching if you want to learn
more about politics and world affairs
and here's some more of my lovely voice
come check out the reconsidered podcast
where we don't do the thinking for you
find reconsider @ww re consider mediacom
or on Apple or Google Play or your
favorite podcast
[Music]